how can Jesus be God if he's the son of
God is he his own son is he his own
father if Jesus is a Son of God then he
can't be God you know how many times
I've heard that silly
objection let's go to Matthew 8:20 so if
Jesus Son of God he can't be God okay
Matthew
8:20 and Jesus said to him foxes have
holes and birds of the air have Nest but
the son of man has nowhere to lay his
head the son of man has nowhere to lay
his head okay did you catch
it if Jesus being the Son of God means
he can't be God then Jesus being the son
of Son of Man means he can't be man he's
not human then what is
he and by the way Jesus didn't have an
Earthly father he didn't have a human
dad so what does son of man mean in
Hebrew it's
benam in the Aramaic of the day
it's today Ians you're going to know the
word
baros
barha this is an Aramaic expression that
means someone who's
human son of man means someone who's
Human by Nature because here son of
means to possess the nature of he's a
son of man and that he possesses the
nature of man he's
human
therefore to be the son of man is to be
a a man to be the son of man is to be
human similarly to be the Son of God is
to be God because to be the Son of God
means you possess the nature of God
hello if you're a son of man then you
must be man you must be Human by Nature
well if you're the Son of God that means
you must be God you must be divine by
Nature hello Jesus can be the Son of God
without being his own father and still
be God in essence because if he's the
Son of God and God is his father that
means he Bears the nature of his
father gee I never thought of
that
wow right just like the son of man is a
man the Son of God is God by Nature so
he can be the Son of God the Father
and yet because God is his father he
shares in the nature of his father so if
his father is
God then he would have the nature of his
father so if his father is divine by
Nature then a son would also be divine
by
Nature oh W oh
W you get it
now let me give you a similar point
let's go to Genesis 5:2 King James
version male and
female created he them and blessed them
and called their name
Adam in the day when they were created
okay what's the female's
name what's the female's
name Genesis 52 one more time what's her
name what's the male's
name what's the male's name the name of
the male is what Adam the name of the
female is what Adam did you catch it
Genesis
52 he created them male and female and
called them named them name the male and
the female Adam so the male is Adam the
female is Adam they're both Adam okay
but hold on I'm confused Genesis 4 verse
one and Adam knew Eve his wife and she
conceived and bears Cain and said I have
gotten a man from the Lord Adam knew Eve
his wife okay so is Eve the wife of
Adam Adam knew Eve his wife is Eve the
wife of
Adam you read it right there Genesis
4:1 okay but I'm confused how can Eve be
the wife of Adam if she's Adam how can
Eve be Adam if she's the wife of
Adam she's the wife of Adam so she can't
be Adam no stupid she can be the wife of
Adam and also be Adam because she's the
wife of Adam the male who's her husband
but like her husband she has Adam by
Nature because the word Adam means human
kind human someone who's Human by Nature
so she is Adam by by nature and married
to Adam because her husband is also Adam
by Nature even though he's a different
person likewise Jesus can be the Son of
God the father but like the father be
God in nature because if God is his
father then he Bears the nature of his
father so he's the son of God because
God is his father and he also Bears the
nature of his father 2 John 1 verse3
Grace be with you mercy and peace from
God the father and from the Lord Jesus
Christ the son of the father in truth
and love so yes Jesus is the son of God
because there he's the son of the Father
and Jesus is not the father but if God
is his father that means he's going to
Bear the nature of his father and what
is his F what is the nature of his
father well his father is God and the
nature of his father is god well if he's
truly the Son of God truly the son of
the father that means he's going to Bear
the nature of his father just like Mary
is human and he's truly the son of Mary
so he Bears the nature of Mary and
therefore he's human like Mary he's a
Son of God in eternity before creation
okay now let's look at the analogy of
Eve again Genesis 5:2 in the King
James male and female created he them
and bled them and called their name Adam
in the day they were created so the male
is Adam the female is Adam and yet the
female is also called Eve and she's the
wife of Adam contradiction no Adam in
Hebrew means mankind Humanity human and
both the male and female are Adam and
that both the male and female are human
in nature so Eve is Adam in nature and
she's married to a person who's also
Adam in nature in fact Eve came out of
Adam
so she is flesh of his flesh bone of his
bones and therefore is one with him in
nature because her husband's nature is
her nature she came out of him so she
Bears his nature so she's one with him
in nature making her fully Adam like her
husband Genesis 2 23-
24 and Adam said this is now bone of my
bones because she came out of his side
God cut open his side and fashion her
Adam said this is now bone of my bones
and Flesh of My Flesh so because she was
made from my bones she is of my bones
because she's made of My Flesh she is of
My
Flesh right she came out of
me and because she came out of me she
possesses my nature and therefore she's
one with me for this reason she she
shall be called woman because she was
taken out of man woman from Man Woman
from the womb of man
that's why she's called woman and then
24 therefore shall a man leave his
father and his mother and shall cleave
unto his wife and they shall be one
flesh you see because she came out of
Adam's Body she came out of Adam's flesh
she came out of Adam's bones she
possesses the nature of Adam because she
comes out of him and is one with him in
nature so she comes out of him and then
reunites with him in intimacy to become
one flesh again so their flesh is one
because her flesh is from his flesh
therefore their nature is one though
they're different persons similarly
Jesus is the Eternal son the Eternal
Word whose nature is his father's nature
his father's nature is his nature
because he's one with the father and
possesses the same nature of his
father
right is it making sense everyone
is it making sense to everyone so can
Jesus be God if he's the son of God of
course he's the son of God the father
and because he's the father's unique son
he Bears the nature of his father so his
father is God by Nature Divine by Nature
so will the son be divine just like if
you were born to a human being you will
bear the nature of that human being
because a son of a man is human a man
son of a dog is a dog the Son of God is
God so where's the
problem where's the
problem is there a problem in fact even
the Jews understood because Jesus was
the unique Son of God the uniquely
begotten Son of
God that Jesus was pretty much claiming
to be God In the Flesh by claiming to be
the Son of God the father so notice two
things and we're going to end it with
this the Jews who heard Jesus understood
that when he claimed to be the Son of
God clearly he was
claiming not to be the father he's not
the father he's the father son but
because he's the unique son of the
father he was claiming to be God In the
Flesh just as much God as his father is
let me repeat it again I want you to get
it one more time I want you to get
it the Jews understood that when Jesus
claimed to be the Son of God they
understood he wasn't claiming to be the
father because he was a son of the
father but they also understood by
making himself out to be the unique son
of the father he was claiming to be God
in nature by claiming to be the unique
Son of God so he's not the father but
being the unique Son of God he's one
with the father in nature and therefore
just as much God as the father is now
let me prove that to you are you
ready John 10
27-33 everyone got it John 10:
27-33 and then we'll end it and we'll
answer the other objections Lord willing
in the near future John 10:27 and33 okay
pay attention folks my sheep hear my
voice and I know them and they follow me
right and I give
them eternal life I give them eternal
life no creature can say no finite
creature can say I give all the Sheep No
matter how numerous I give them Immortal
Life NeverEnding life I make them
physically indestructible deathless by
Nature
morally Incorruptible so they can live
forever in my presence no creature can
say that but Jesus just said it I give
them eternal life they shall never
perish neither shall anyone snatch them
out of my hand no creature can say that
there is no power to dislodge the sheep
from my hand because there is no power
equal to my power or greater than my
power to stop me from preserving my
sheep forever no creature can talk like
this my father who given them to me is
greater than all and no one is able to
snatch them out of my father's now that
makes sense because the father's God
Almighty so there is no power that can
dislodge Believers from The Sovereign
protective hand and care of the father
but then he says I and my father are
one we are one in our ability to
preserve all believers Incorruptible and
there's no power that can stop us from
preserving them forever
so now notice their
reaction he didn't post 31 good job
buddy at this they picked up stones to
Stone him 32 Jesus answered them many
good works I have shown you from the
father for which of those Works do you
Stone me now notice their answer
33 the Jews answered him saying for good
work we do not Stone you but for
blasphemy because you being a man make
yourself God oh wow
here it is notice the Jews correctly
understood this man this Jewish man is
claiming to be God but then they thought
he can't be possibly be God so he's
blaspheming the Jews answered him saying
for good work we do not Stone you but
for blasphemy and because you being a
man make yourself God number one he
never said I am
God he said he's the son of God distinct
from the father but one with the father
and their ability to preserve all
believers
Incorruptible he didn't need to say I am
God because they
understood that though he's not claiming
to be the father whom we know to be God
we know the father's God but you're not
claiming to be the
father you're claiming to be the son of
the father who can do what the father
does but what the father does is
something that only God can do now we
expect the father to do it because he's
clearly God but you're a man how can you
claim to be the son of the father who
can do what the father does because the
things that the father does only God
Almighty can do who do you think you are
to make yourself to be God Almighty
though you're a man and you're not the
father now notice John
197 that's why the Jews correct ly
reason he was claiming to be God
Almighty In the Flesh though not the
father but then they were incorrect to
assume that he's a deceiver a liar for
claiming that and tried to kill him
because notice what they say in John
197 the Jews answered him we have a law
and according to the LA to our law he
ought to die because he made himself the
Son of God why God had many sons and
daughters none of them were killed
because the understood he's not claiming
to be a mere son of God like us he's
claiming to be the
unique Son of God the uniquely begotten
Son of God who is equal to his father in
nature and ability who can do whatever
the father does in the same way the
father does it and yet the father being
God does things only God can do so this
man this Jewish man and claiming to be
that kind of Son of God is virtually
claiming to God In the
Flesh so what's the point Jesus can be
the Son of God who's God in nature
because number one he's the son of God
the father he's not the father but the
father son number two because he's the
unique son of the the father he Bears
the nature of his father to the same
degree and to the same extent that the
father Bears the divine nature he's just
as much God as the father is even though
he's not the father and hence by
claiming to be that kind of Son of God
he was virtually claiming to be God
Almighty in human flesh though he's not
the father is that clear